the type of debt that most of us are
most familiar with are mortgages that we
might take out on our homes what i want
to do in this video is clarify how a
mortgage is different than the type of
debt that many corporations would take
on so if i were to take out a million
dollar mortgage what happens is that the
bank figures out a fixed payment that i
could pay really every month
and as i pay that payment and that
payment will not change over the course
of the term of that mortgage so maybe
it's a 10-year mortgage the payment
won't change but as i pay that mortgage
i pay some some part of it is interest
and some part of it is actually paying
down the mortgage so early on in the
life of the mortgage maybe this is the
first payment here most of the payment
is going to be interest
is going to be interest and a little bit
of the mortgage is going to be the
mortgage payment is going to be
principal and when i say principal that
little pink part right there that's
actually being used to pay down the debt
on the mortgage so after this first
payment now the debt is a little bit
less i'm going to make the same total
mortgage payment but since the debt is
now less the total debt is now less the
amount i'm taking the same interest rate
i'm assuming it's a fixed interest rate
here but the amount of interest is going
to be less because i paid off a little
bit of the principal already so on the
next payment the amount of interest is
going to be a little bit less
and for that fixed payment that i'm
making i'm now going to be able to give
more principal
and we keep doing that so we keep doing
that so i'm going to do that same color
so the next payment after that nope
that's not the same color
the next payment after that even though
it's the exact same payment
it's going to have less interest because
i've paid down more of the debt now so
it's going to have less interest and it
normally doesn't happen this quickly but
i hopefully this gives you the idea and
it's also going to have more principle
so that you fast forward all the way to
near the end of the term so this is many
payments later this is the end of the 10
years if i i think i said this was a
10-year mortgage loan on that last
payment even though every payment was
exactly the same amount the mortgage
payment was the same dollar amount every
month that last payment is going to be
very little interest is going to be very
little interest
and mostly principal
and then after that last payment
you would or if i'm the person taking
out the mortgage loan i would have paid
off of the law paid off the loan
so loan paid off
loan
paid off and i own the house i own the
house outright in a traditional fixed
rate mortgage
with corporate debt it's not always like
that in fact it's not usually like that
corporate debt is usually interest only
debt and there's there usually there
might be some things where the
corporation has to pay off certain
amounts of the loans at certain types
but it isn't the model where you have a
fixed payment and you pay off the debt
over a certain amount of time most
corporate debt let's say a corporation
takes a million dollars in debt and
let's say it's a 10-year loan as well
but the corporation is just going to pay
the interest only
is going to pay the interest only the
entire time so whatever this amount was
roughly is what the what the corporation
will pay every month
so they'll pay exactly that much every
time period maybe every quarter every
year whatever it might be and then you
fast forward
you fast forward to the end of the term
of the loan
so they continue paying that same amount
and at the end of the term of the loan
they have to pay that amount
plus
all of the principal at once
plus all of the principal at once now
most companies won't have all of that
principle sitting around so whatever it
might be they have to pay all of the
principal at once at the end of the term
of the loan
and well if they have the cash they
could pay off the loan but if they don't
have the cash and most corporations
would not have the cash in the situation
that's why they borrowed it in the first
place what they would do is they would
take out a new loan so they would take
out a new loan for the same amount of
principal so they'll maybe to the same
bank maybe a different bank but it might
now have a different interest rate
different loan terms whatever so they'll
now take out a new loan at the end of
the term period use that to pay the
principal on their old loan and then
they'll continue paying interest for the
term of this new loan so it's a slightly
different process and i just wanted to
make sure you understood that and the
other thing this isn't all corporate
debt and they could be fixed interest
rate floating interest rate there's
often things called covenants
covenants that the bank will place on
the corporation to make sure that the
corporation isn't doing dangerous things
that will make it less likely that
they'll eventually be able to pay off
the debt or less likely they could
eventually get a loan to pay off the
current loan so it's it there are
controls that the bank has to make sure
that uh the the company is good for this
near the end of the term but as you can
see it's a fundamentally different
process than most mortgage loans